los campeones Defensores han aterrizado
en Qatar llegaron a doha el miércoles
por la noche en vísperas de la Copa
Mundial de 2022 los preparativos han
estado dominados por la polémica para el
presidente francés esa polémica ya es
innecesaria creo que no hay que
politizar el deporte estas cuestiones
deben plantearse cuando se adjudican los
eventos es cuando se adjudican los
partidos ya sean mundiales o juegos
olímpicos cuando debemos plantearnos
Honestamente la pregunta pero para
muchos el torneo es mucho más que fútbol
en Qatar el matrimonio entre personas
del mismo sexo está castigado con la
muerte algo por lo que muchos equipos
piensan protestar El capitán de Francia
Hugo lloris ya ha indicado que no
llevará el brazalete arcoiris que se
lucirá El capitán de Inglaterra Harry
kane entre otros pero su equipo se ha
comprometido a apoyar económicamente a
la ong que ayudan a proteger los
Derechos Humanos sin embargo otros
equipos se arriesgan a recibir multas
por protestar contra las leyes anti lgbt
de sus países Estados Unidos ha colocado
insignias con arcoiris en sus
instalaciones de entrenamiento mientras
que Inglaterra llegó al país en un avión
llamado Rainbow la FIFA ha intentado
frenar estas formas de protesta y su
presidente gianni infantino ha enviado
una carta a las 32 naciones
participantes pidiéndoles que se
abstengan de dar lecciones Morales al
resto del mundo una carta que fue
rechazada casi de inmediato por varias
de las principales naciones europeas
entre ellas Inglaterra y Bélgica cuyas
asociaciones de fútbol emitieron un
comunicado conjunto en respuesta abrazar
la diversidad y la tolerancia también
significa apoyar los Derechos Humanos
los Derechos Humanos son universales y
se aplican en todas partes las
condiciones de trabajo también están en
la agenda de algunas naciones miles de
trabajadores migrantes murieron en los
preparativos del torneo lo que ha
llevado a Países Bajos a anunciar que
subastará sus camisetas y que los
beneficios se destinarán a apoyar a los
trabajadores emigrantes en de